On January 23rd a family in China
traveled from Wuhan to the city of
Guangzhou the next day they ate lunch at
a restaurant one of them had Kovan 18
but didn't feel sick yet within a few
days other members of the family started
showing symptoms and a few days after
that so did the family who was sitting
at the table next to them the family at
this table also got sick and researchers
say this first person was the source of
all these infections even though some of
them were sitting almost 14 feet away
but the people eating that these tables
didn't get sick why an air conditioning
unit right here kept the air flowing
through this section of the restaurant
it circulated the virus from this person
through the air to these other families
the story highlights something about the
corona virus most of us are just
starting to understand its ability to
travel through the air and as public
spaces open up that's led to some big
questions is it safe to go to the beach
what about a park and is a runner gonna
get you sick if we think about our
actions only in terms of safe or risky
there's really only one way to guarantee
that you won't get sick or spread Kovan
19 stay home isolate yourself and have
zero contact with the outside world but
maintaining that level of caution all
the time isn't really possible for most
of us we need food we need supplies and
sometimes we just need to take a walk so
the goal in protecting yourself and
others from Kovan 18 isn't to eliminate
risk completely it's to minimize it if
this side is perpetual quarantine and
this side is getting coughed on by a
bunch of sick people it's about pushing
yourself as reasonably close to this
side as you can so let's start with
going for a walk and with someone who
like me has also felt weird about it
before I started calling up
epidemiologists and talking to them
about the risks I was actually pretty
paranoid and then when I actually
started digging into the research I
realized the risks of getting coated
from runners or cyclists outside
is much lower than I thought every time
we breathe but especially when we talk
and especially when we cough or sneeze
we let out little droplets of water some
of them are pretty big and heavy and
fall to the ground quickly like little
bits of spit others are really small and
much lighter so they float farther
through the air and these droplets are
what's carrying the virus if a droplet
floats and then evaporates
that leaves the virus out in the air for
some period of time and we don't yet
know the amount of virus you have to be
exposed to to get sick but we do know
that you lower your risk by exposing
yourself to less of the virus and Segal
says there's three ways to do that the
first is distance so are you six feet
away from the person duration are you
encountering this person for one second
as they whizzed past you or are you
around them for an hour and ventilation
is there a good airflow moving around
you that can disperse any viral
particles or are you in an enclosed
indoor space where they're just gonna
stick around the difference between how
air moves inside versus outside it's
huge to show that I used this spray
which glows under a blacklight I sprayed
my test subject with it both inside and
outside from three feet away even though
it wasn't windy far fewer Spray
particles reached his shirt outside the
airflow was so much better at dispersing
them and being outside also has an
effect on the virus itself a virus has
this protective coat of moisture around
it there's a lot of things acting on it
so there's sunlight hitting it there's
wind there's rain there's humidity and
all of that can work to kind of break
apart this protective coat of moisture
and decay the virus a study in China
looked at 318 different outbreaks of
Kovan 19 across the country only one of
them involves someone catching it
outdoors that study hasn't been
peer-reviewed but it's consistent with
everything else we know that being
outside can be pretty low risk but your
interactions with other people can
increase that risk if you're talking to
a friend at a close distance your risk
goes up and that risk climbs the longer
your converse a
continues but if you're both wearing
masks to stop some of those larger
droplets from spreading your risk goes
down shopping in an open-air market is
less risky than being inside a store but
you can reduce that risk by getting in
and out quickly but what about passing a
heavy breathing runner so let me take
you through what would actually have to
happen for a runner or cyclist outside
to infect you as they pass by they would
have to expel enough viral particles to
be able to kick-start an infection those
particles would have to travel several
feet of distance withstand the pressures
of wind rain humidity then the particles
have to actually land in your throat or
your upper respiratory tract or on your
hands which you would then use to touch
your eyes your nose or your mouth so all
of that is a pretty arduous sequence to
execute perfectly going to the beach or
to a park isn't necessarily dangerous or
safe the risk can go up or down
depending on how we each behave which
means everyone has a responsibility to
lower that risk for everyone else the
point here is not to be cavalier when
you go outside I think we all still want
to be cautious especially as some states
are starting a reopening changing your
behavior to limit exposure to the virus
won't reduce your risk to zero but it
could lower it enough that you can
breathe a little easier
[Music]